maintenant que la réouverture de
l'économie s'amorce plusieurs employés
doivent retourner au travail
certains vont préférer rester à la
maison pour une question financière ou
par crainte d'attraper lakovic 19
eric l'allier est avocat spécialisé en
droit du travail chez norton rose faudra
et eric l'allier bonsoir bonsoir
monsieur fluence est ce qu'une personne
qui a été mis à pied à cause la kfw 19
qui reçoit la prestation canadienne
d'urgence qui est maintenant rappelés au
travail a le droit de rester chez elle
et de conserver les pc la réponse 5-1
légalement c'est non en fait c'est à
dire que le régime la prestation
canadienne d'urgence a été fait pour
permettre aux gens qui avaient perdu
leur emploi temporairement de bénéficier
d'une aide qui était elle-même qualifiée
d' urgence par contre il soit + 4 est
actuellement auquel les entreprises font
face
ce qu'on a procédé à des mises à pied
massives mais temporaire et l'on
effectué des rappels
on parle de reprise d'activité
redémarrage des entreprises et sape les
employés pour mais manifestent leur
désir de plutôt de rester à la maison
pour bénéficier de la prestation
canadienne d'urgence mais c'est très
clair le seul motif c'est à dire si
c'est celui ci le seul motif de le
continuer de toucher la paix su si
certainement pas une raison pour ne pas
se présenter au travail et il ya le
concept des filles de mises à pied
temporaires qui font en sorte qu'on a
maintenu dans le fond et lien d'emploi
exact en fait la mise à pied temporaire
et au québec c'est pour une durée de six
mois maximum
saha suspendez effet si vous me
permettez du contrat de travail le
contrat de travail la relation entre
l'employeur et l'employé elle elle
existe toujours
donc à partir du moment où l'emploi lui
demande on en plus de revenir et
activent le contrat de travail ses
effets personnels l'employé lui ai tenu
aussi de sa contrepartie puis celle de
donner sa prestation de travail de s'y
présenter
à moins bien sûr qu'ils aient des motifs
injustifiés pour s'absenter et on
pourrait penser entre autres quelqu'un
qui souffre de la maladie ont été en
contact avec la proximité avec quelqu'un
qui souffre de maladies etc
alors là on tombe dans un autre régime
se c'est celui de la justification des
absences mais
si on revient la question d'entrée c'est
lorsque pour ce motif leur celui de
maintenir la paix sûre on peut refuser
compte tenu de la réactivation des
effectifs contre travail la réponse est
non qu'arrive-t-il donc à une personne
qui dit mais moi je retourne pas au
travail
je veux conserver mon pc je ne retourne
pas au travail
faites ce que vous voulez je ne retourne
pas au travail qu'est ce qui lui arrive
est cette personne
moi c'est ce que j'appelle un pari
risqué parce que la résultante la
conclusion tout ça ça risque
effectivement que la personne perdre son
emploi
alors de deux choses l'une soit
considéré que la personne à abandonner
volontairement son travail qu'elle a
démissionné soit on estimerait que les
motifs de congédiement la conclusion
comme je dis c'est la même celle à fort
prix la relation d'emploi la fin du
contrat de travail la rupture et à ce
moment là bas qui sait après les 16
semaines
en fait qui s'est même si vous
maintiendrez toujours droit à la
prestation de même si à l'expiration de
cette même pcu lorsqu'ils viendront
puisqu'elle sera en fête le le portrait
du du milieu du travail en ce moment de
filer personne est congédié est-ce
qu'elle aura droit à l'assurance-emploi
la réponse technique légale c'est une
honte à dire que lorsqu'il ya un
congédiement pau 1 conduite par une
personne qu'ils refuseraient de se
présenter au travail pourrait ne pas
recevoir des prestations d'assurance
emploi ultérieur
évidemment c'est à la discrétion de
l'agent qui traite la demande à
l'association plein de facteurs qui
peuvent entrer en ligne de compte mais
de façon théorique la réponse
effectivement l'employé risque de ne pas
recevoir une prestation de la piste où
l'assurance emploi s'il démissionne donc
quitte volontairement son emploi elle
n'a plus droit à la prestation
canadienne d'urgence on l'a bien compris
est ce que le droit à l'assurance-emploi
même même conclusion c'est à dire que à
ce moment le nom l'assurance emploi non
plus ne s'appliquera pas et la personne
des tables maryse de se retrouver sans
moyens et est même peut-être davantage
encore c'est à dire que lorsque des
vérifications sur entreprises pourraient
même avoir remboursé une portion de la
prestation est important de dire aussi
que les règles sont différentes entre la
pcu la prestation canadienne d'urgence
et l'assurance emploi l'assurance emploi
c'est de rester disponible pour le
travail
oui des régimes qui sont complémentaires
le premier pcu qui vise à aider les gens
dans la période d'urgence crucial qu'on
actuellement dans ce régime il n'y a pas
d'obligation de tenter de se trouver un
emploi ou de tenter de rester disponible
à l'emploi alors que en matière
d'assurance emploi lorsqu'on applique
les règles usuelles
je voudrais qu actuellement le plus
grand chose du duel lorsqu'on a plus que
les règles usuelles
effectivement il faut rester disponible
effectué des démarches en ce sens là il
ya une question qui revient souvent eric
la leaf et je vais vous la soumettre
parce qu'on on la reçoit de bien des
gens qui nous la pause
est ce que refuse de retourner au
travail pour un travailleur de plus de
70 en train de la perdre la paix c'est
parce qu'on sait que on demande aux gens
qui ont plus de 70 ans c'est pas un
ordre formel et la police n'est pas en
avant de la maison pour vérifier là mais
on demande aux gens de 70 ans et plus en
raison des craintes plus grande sur la
santé est ce que un refus de retourner
au travail pour une personne de 70 ans
et plus en train de la perdre la
prestation canadienne d'urgence c'est
une question beaucoup plus complexe qui
commandent certaines nuances en fait ce
que je recommande mon côté puis on y
fait face à ces questions actuellement
c'est de regarder un peu la situation
ils sont peut accommoder ou arriver à
une entente avec l'employé pour retirer
préventivement cet emploi puisqu'il est
à risque du milieu de travail est de
reconnaître que c'est une situation où
préventive
à mon sens la prestation canadienne de
jaloux devraient tous application il a
pris pour en bénéficient par contre je
l'avais bien dit ans pas une obligation
une recommandation au gouvernement du
québec le même reconnu lorsque la
personne est en bonne santé physique et
radar services sociaux on peut même lui
demander de travailler alors évidemment
si c'était dans un contexte où la
personne avait besoin d'elle on devait
lui demander d'autre que sa prestation
de travail qui avait pas de contraintes
médicales précises et le la situation
beaucoup moins clair à mon sens et on
rencontrerait peut-être paul critères
d'admissibilité de la paix du qe2
d'avoir perdu involontairement son
travail une personne qui dit avoir une
santé fragile wet avec quelqu'un dont la
santé est fragile peut être refusé de
retourner au travail
là encore il faut il faut évidemment que
le motif soit la soie existants moi
j'invite les employeurs à la flexibilité
au dialogue avec leurs employés puis
évidemment c'est peut-être plus
difficile actuellement d'avoir des
éléments qui attestent de la difficulté
médical de la personne avec qui on
réside de bord du terrain
donc il faut vraiment faire attention
mais je pense que dans un cas comme
celui-là c'était quelque chose de
documenter qu'on avait besoin de 13 ans
pour aider la personne avec qui on
réside ce c'est peut-être un motif
qu'ils ont effectivement perry que
l'allié merci très clair très apprécié
mais cerveau